こんにちははじめしゃちょーとこんばんは
モンゴリアンチョップまさやです
モンゴリアンチョップまさにお久しぶりで
ございます
確かにたまには
遊びに来てるんですけども動画出るのは
もう1年以上ぶりぐらいですねあなたと
いえばこれ
心霊スポットいきたいと思います
来てしまいましたもう怖すぎてあの
ブレーキのペダルずっと組んでて後ろが
真っ赤です
話しますいやでもまさやといえばやっぱ僕
の静岡大学の後輩ということで今で静岡の
心霊スポットいろいろ見てきたんですけど
ももうマジでないということで今回どこ
ですか
東京の東京の特別に
特別に強化を取って
廃墟に行きたいと思います
いやなかなかねそのなんかトンネルとか
なんか山とかそういうのじゃなくて場所と
か施設とか建物ってすごい客はどれが
難しくてそうですよねはいかなりハードル
が高いんですけども私の実績があってなん
とか特別になるほど
オーナー今回は
なりましたはい今回は建物でございます
もう廃墟なので誰も進んでないし誰も生活
をしてないっていう場所になってます今回
行く場所は
武井壮というだけそうアパートに言うと
思った東京の都内にあるアパートの一室が
あれば見学入室が可能らしいで
ぶっちゃけ何かその場所自体に事件とかが
あったわけじゃないらしいんですよ
誰かが自殺したとか価値があったとかでは
なく
噂も
噂はありますなんか結構広いらしくて絶対
で家族でそれぐらいのん
結構広いから家族で住むことが面積がそう
ですただ
不思議なことに結構
早々に退去される方が多い物件だし
入ってすぐ出ちゃうそうこれなんか曰く
付きです
はい
正直さー待機はされるとさ元気ないわけ
じゃんあーもう出ちゃった後っすもんね
一般の人だから退去されてたゲーム
わからないから何かあったとかも全く
なんか情報がないらしいんですけどもそう
いう事故物件とか廃墟に食わしい人が調べ
たところを昔この地域周辺になんか施設が
あったらしくてそういうちょっと実験
できるマスみたいなそこでちょっとなんか
違法的な人体実験みたいなのが行われてた
らしくてでそこも普通に敵はされちゃって
開発は中止になったらしいんですけども
なんと位置的にはこのアパート今から行く
武装とアパートが
ちょうどその
施設の場所だったらしいです
専門家が言ってるんですよ僕たちより先に
これ僕たち行く必要ありますですよね実際
に足を運んでますやさん霊感があって
過去を進んでスポット言った時になんと
帰ってから車を壊してしまったという
2回止まりましたけどね2階とも頂いて
おりますありがとうございます最強の霊感
の能力の持ってる人なのできっと何か起き
てほしい願わくば起きてほしいという非常
に悪い対応決めて今日も行ってみたいと
思います
僕だけ無事に帰ります逆ですさあもう早速
着くまで来てるので行きましょうかはい
行きます
ね
何してるとか言っていいの何してる
何して
思います
それは
そんな都会チックなところにそんなところ
あるんですかいやなんか
俺も何回か行ったことあるんだけどやっぱ
そういう例とかってさ人が集まる場所に
木とかっててくるらしいからこれも早速
救急車だもんもう
ほらもう
確定演出何歳やとトリンドルレイナの共通
点を5つ上げよう
人大
呼吸
これは
右側右側
終わってない
えそうなの
暴露を最初にした女の名前もレイなんだよ
いやなんかすごいのがさあ今の若い子たち
俺の3また事件とか知らないんだよ
えもっと言った方がいいっすよちゃんと
ややこしいやん
絶対
知らないでいい
のさ最近なんかマジいって面でさこうやっ
たら出てくんだよ
どうも
イケメンです嘘でしょう
甘すぎる
ここら辺かにゃあここ
ら辺ですね
着きましたうわ
不安ここですここはいマジで普通の
古い感じの商店街的な感じではあるけど
ですねこの中にあるみたいですじゃあ早速
いきたいと思います行くぞ
はいというわけで着きました
ぽいね
人もさっきを抜いたしさ
普通にお店とかもたくさんあったのにさ
こういう路地裏に突然出てくるんだよ
階段やば
何何何どうしたどうした踏み外しました
人生かこちらですね
オーナーさんが出てくれてるのでそこから
入れます行きますね行きましょう
[音楽]
ボロボロだなんか作りが独特で1回もあと
こっちしか行けなくて
[音楽]
急遽しかないよね
行こうか
戦闘やばいいきますねとりあえず
開けましょう
ここは俺が開けるから次開けてね開けます
お酒好きだったんだろうなぁ
[音楽]
どういう作りこれ
えっその廊下すごいよねたださ他検証って
さあれじゃないデュオみたいな何そうって
さなんかあれじゃん10
説明できねえよ同じ建物の中にそれぞれ
部屋で
誰かが住んでる
みたいな感じだと思う
その異質がここってことに
土足で失礼します
見てません見てキキララがいるよまだこれ
それは2枚
これが一番好きなんじゃないドラミちゃん
見て見て
うわ
携帯固まっとるやんちょっと
待ってあー無理だ
動いたはい
床がめっちゃ柔らかいですこれね
廊下ですねなんか量って感じするよね
[音楽]
いやもうこれ外に繋がってるわ
えマジですかここ行ってみますねはい
失礼しますだいぶ
来てるなぁ
お願いします
なんかありますまず
結構
うわぁ
そういうことしたそこ抜けてるよ
危ないですねここはちょっと
危険かもしれないですねこれ
足がすごいさ柔らかいよねちょっと針確認
しようかな
こういう部屋が何個かあるんでしょうね
ここは
寒気がやばいんだけどずっと
[音楽]
藤枝から買っトイレ見てみます
意外と綺麗
なのってなんかいいことだよね
あれ開いてるんですか
開いてるえさっき開けました
[音楽]
え
っ
いきましょう
びっくりした
ちょっと今結構お腹に詰めてるから
え
何の音これんん
何で上から足音するんですか
聞こえてないですかそれがまさやあの
ショートかなと思ってここにぶつかったん
ですよ
びっくりして俺も
びっくりして
止まってたんですけど
メイク
ちょっと
上見て帰ろうですねどうすか
[音楽]
めっちゃ怖えーこっから
すいませんそこで待ってて
[音楽]
さっきマジで
上でこれ3階あります
その
[音楽]
上だったんだよな
絶対部屋の上天井屋根裏とか
早く来てほしい
[音楽]
ここは普通に廊下になっててまあそこも
また外すんだまだ2回ちょっと綺麗そうね
なんかこっちの部屋にこっちが気になるよ
ねさっきの
ドンって音いきましょうか
じゃあ奥の部屋行って帰ろう
僕の部屋で帰ります
[音楽]
名前だ
のりづき雅彦
やってますはい
失礼しますね
とりあえず誘ってもらいますなる
ほどなるほどね
トイレ
[音楽]
顔色めっちゃ悪いよやばい本当にやばい
釣るやんどんどん
見て戻ろうとりあえず
奥の部屋
それ以外は
何も
なさそうちょっと開いてるの声なこれ
焼けらんないっすよこれ
戻りますわ
えっ
ヤバい
笑えない本当に
待って待って
えここのその重かったすか
重かったの
他の扉
鳥肌やばい
え
押すですよね
引いたオスです
押し返された
気がしたんですけどね
違うおかしいから俺がおかしいだけか
やばい
手をちょっとなんかマジでやばいあーもう
だめだ
本当に無理だ
本当に無理だよ
無理だ
よ普通にここ無理だ
本当にやばい
霊的じゃなくて普通におかしいこの家
物理的にってこと
で
探せ
[拍手]
[音楽]
マジでやばい
心霊スポットということでこっそりあのー
人体実験で失敗された皆さんを配置させて
いただいておりましたなるほど
言ったことは割とガチで言ってるじゃん
言ってますね昔のテンションで言ってる
から
逆にガチャで最初に行くところに仕掛け
てるとどうなることと思ったらまさやさん
倒れてしまいました
体調の方もノートとか聞こえたりしたのは
全部ゾンビさんたちのちょっとした弟とか
であしっかりと拾ってくださって
ありがとうございます
俺のプランとは全く別のとこで動いてたら
僕も正直してました
忘れたまた来年も心霊スポットいき
ましょう
お願いします